it's been described as kleptocracy at
its worst
a fund set up by the malaysian
government under former prime minister
najib razak
to promote economic development in the
country used instead
as a vehicle for theft u.s and malaysian
authorities say four and a half billion
dollars
is believed to have been stolen from the
fund now goldman sachs
the investment bank that helped raise
billions of dollars in bonds for one
mdb has agreed to pay back nearly three
billion dollars for its role in the
scandal
today's resolution is significant it
includes criminal charges against the
bank
and a guilty plea by its malaysian
subsidiary
it also requires goldman to discourage
the entirety
of its 600 million dollar profit pay a
2.3
billion dollar penalty and admit
wrongdoing
malaysian and u.s prosecutors allege the
bond sales provided one of the ways for
associates of nuget to steal from the
fund
investigators say the stolen money was
used to bribe corrupt officials
buy luxury assets and even finance a
hollywood film
over a billion dollars changing hands
that was going to
foreign officials there's use of um
uh shell companies and and holding
companies and so forth to funnel this
money and of course that's money that
could be going to
uh people citizens of those countries
that could use it so
uh it's really i think a story that goes
beyond the actions of one particular
financial institution
goldman sachs reached a 3.9 billion
settlement deal with the malaysian
government in july
in exchange for malaysian prosecutors
dropping charges against it
the same month former prime minister
najib was found guilty of corruption and
money laundering charges
linked to a subsidiary of 1 mdb
najib is appealing against his
conviction and is being tried
on dozens of other charges related to
one mdb other people have been caught up
in the scandal
the u.s justice department has filed
criminal charges against two former
goldman sachs bankers
u.s and malaysian authorities are
seeking malaysian financier
low-tech joe known as joe lowe who's
accused of having played a central role
in the fraud
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur